no there's two there's two go to-- sorry
now we're heading to a cast screening of
The Wedding ringer I'm really excited I
believe it comes out in January next
year so I'm pretty pumped about it Kevin
Hart is in it I love him he's so funny
like he's so funny oh yeah yeah
we gotta go we gotta go here we go I'll
give you your best get to my purse
obviously don't you scared me cuz it was
starting to get close to the top no
gentle is picking a blood blister
stomping I was gonna bleed the whole way
in the theater and I don't have a
band-aid you have a band-aid no so we're
on our way
I don't know I'm actually gonna be able
to vlog at all during it because
sometimes it's a little embarrassing to
vlog in public like not not in public
when I don't know anybody but when I
know people it's a little more
embarrassed I'm like these aren't like
you to people you know you're not dude I
don't think it's a blood line something
in there you see it I got a drive so I
hit the tip I can't I gosh look at my
flash tattoo I look so good look at that
can you believe it finally I've only
known over 72 years I find and I had to
beg we'll see just having better happens
if I know what you do I know you love
the fragile can you this see me as dark
again yeah don't you look great oh yeah
really nice hi so I just got home I
forgot the vlog when I left the theater
but oh my god this movie is so freakin
funny I was dying I was laughing so hard
parts that probably I should have been
laughing at because I thought they're
still funny it was so good and I did
make a little cameo so you guys will
have to check it out just most likely
gonna be a right at our film so if
you're not old enough to see it then you
may not see it Jenna did you like the
movie
my god so funny dying laughing really I
love Kevin Hart it was really really
funny
let me to go and edit this video and
tomorrow I'm gonna film a little video
with Jenna doing the whisper challenge
so leave me some comments below of
things that you would like for me to
whisper to Jenna and you guys will see
that video tomorrow so can I just go
read them no you could not you know to
read them I'm really amore
deenis maro I